within the topic of three-dimensional
vectors we're going to have a look at
something called
ratio division or division of an
interval
now the hardest part of this is nothing
to do with the three-dimensionality of
the vectors we're having a look at at
extension two
uh it's really to do about understanding
the geometry of dividing something
in ratio so the best way to kind of
cover the theory of this
is to have a look at an example question
so let's tuck into this
questions will naturally arise as we go
through about what different things mean
and what potential scenarios can arrive
out of that so we'll tackle them
we'll cross those ridges as we meet them
use vector methods
to find the coordinates of the point c
that divides the interval
joining a and you get the coordinates
and b
in the ratio two to three okay so what's
happening here what we want to first do
is get a sense of geometrically
what does this question even mean when
you say that you are dividing an
interval um a b uh the interval joining
a
and b in a particular ratio what does
that even look like
now this is one of those several
situations where drawing a diagram is
more or less essential
but for this particular kind of question
as i kind of alluded to before
having adding like three dimensions in
your diagram doesn't particularly add
much to your ability to solve
the question you can really think of
this actually mostly in 2d terms
and the clue that tells you that is that
really this question
is about finding some point c and what
you're dividing this is the the clue
like if you're wondering
how do i know when it's important to
have my you know uh
coordinate system set up and have all my
three axes and when is it not important
well have a look at what the question
requires of you you're finding point c
which is dividing an interval
right now an interval is in fact itself
a one-dimensional object that you can
understand in two dimensions
um just if i you know point pick out two
points a
and b and then just join them together
with an interval
then you can see i can just think of
that only in
a two-dimensional sense so therefore a
three-dimensional diagram
isn't necessarily going to help you here
how do i then represent what's going on
between a and b
and this ratio division well if we set
out some
arbitrary a and another arbitrary
b we have an interval joining these two
and i can sort of represent it like
so and to divide this interval into the
ratio 2 to 3
means that i'm going to pick out markers
such that when i
put point c on one of those markers then
the ratio between
the left hand side and the right hand
side will be 2 to 3. now if you want
one component to be two and the other
component to be three that's the ratio
two to three
then you're obviously going to need five
components in total
five parts so let me show you what that
looks like if i were to try and divide
this up into
five equal sections i think it would
look something like that
and what i could say is well if i
highlighted this section
here it would be in a ratio of 2
to 3 with this other section
over here so you can literally see the
two to three ratio there
okay now what we're trying to do there
for is to find that point uh right in
there right in there and that'll be our
point c
that divides the interval accordingly so
i'm going to
put c right there okay
now how do we use uh vector methods as
the question has specified in order to
find
point c well if you have a think about
this you think about the
arithmetic of vectors that you know
about the thing that can help us here is
the scalar
multiple of a vector if we for example
could say we know what vector a b is
ah let me put it across the top in in
green right
vector a b right the way you could find
c
is to say well if you start from a and
go
some proportion of vector a b
i should have labeled that this is what
we would call a b
if you can find the correct proportion
of
vector a b then that'll take you
straight from a
to c or of course you could go from b to
c if you like but
ac is in the same direction as a b so it
seems more sensible
to start from a now how would you do
that well again i mentioned it's with
this scalar multiple
of the vector because i've divided up
this whole interval into
five equal parts and what i want is this
part here which is
two-fifths of the entire interval
therefore
vector ac is equal to
literally two-fifths of vector a-b
you see that it's going in the same
direction the scalar multiple out the
front there that coefficient doesn't
change the direction
it just changes the magnitude right
which is exactly what we want we only
want
two-fifths of the magnitude that will
get us um this two
to three ratio so in order to find
um ac which will give us the coordinates
of c
what i need first is to find a b and
then i can use that as my stepping stone
so that's going to be our path to this
question i'm going to find out what a b
is because that vector is not provided
in the question i need to work out what
it is
and then i'm going to use a b to work
out ac and
once i do that there's just a little bit
of leg work to work out the coordinates
obviously
that's where we're going to go now to
work out what the
vector a b is equal to
in terms of the vectors i already know
because i've got a
i could say i have a position vector for
a
and i've got a position vector for b
based on their coordinates
again a handy diagram will help you out
here right so what i do is i consider
the position vectors for each of these
a and b relative to the origin so if i'm
starting here
at the origin i can say well o a is
going to be
going in that correct direction by the
way is going to be the vector
2 negative 3 10 in column form in fact i
could even write it like so
2 negative 3 and then 10.
and i guess i could call that you know
little a with
the little tilde underneath it and then
little b
vector ob is going to be let's have a
look here i've got negative 3
and then 12 and then 0 is my
z vector there now in order to get a b
which you can see
i guess we would represent i mean i used
green before didn't i
like so this is the a b that i'm after
the easiest way to do that is to say
well i want to start from a
and get to b the way that i can compose
the vectors i already know
is to go backwards not from o to a this
this will take me from o to a but to go
from a to o and then o
to b so this is the the set of vectors
that i'm going to string together
right a to o and then
o to b and you can see here
if i'm carrying on this color here to go
from a to o
will be negative of this little a vector
because i'm going in the opposite
direction magnitude same direction i'm
just going to flip
all of the signs so therefore what i can
say is
a b is going to be equal to uh what did
we say
a o plus
o b uh but what that's really equal to
is negative of what i know
little a vector is going to be so really
that is
let's see here negative oh sorry i've
already put the
negative out the front 2 negative 3
10 and then i'm going to add negative 3
12 0. so if you wanted some people are
going to go straight to
that vector and say it's going to be ob
take away o
a i i haven't written it like that
immediately because
it sort of seems weird to say ob and
then do a which actually sends me over
here
because of the parallelogram law if you
think about what happens when you go
here and then here you are going to get
the same
a b vector over there just translated
elsewhere it's the opposite side of the
parallelogram
but i think this is a more helpful way
to see what's going on
using vector methods right okay so now
that i've got my vectors down we can
actually go ahead and we can compute
this so
uh what do we got i'm going to have
negative 2 3 and
negative 10 and then what i'm adding is
this negative 3
i'm going to add 12 and then comes a 0
along the end here okay what does that
give us well
it looks like i'm going to get negative
5
i've got 15 in the middle there and then
negative 10. okay let's have a quick
look that all seems fine to me happy
times
so what i've got now is vector a b but
you'll recall
i didn't want actually vector a b that
was just
a stepping stone to get to a c hc
is two fifths of the way from a to b so
all i need to do
to turn this into ac is to multiply it
by
two-fifths so i can say ac
therefore this equals two-fifths
of the vector that we calculated up here
so uh if we have a think about this um
i'm going to be
um dividing by five then doubling that's
not too hard because conveniently
it's almost like this question was
designed for this purpose everything
here is a multiple
of five so if i go ahead and do my
scalar multiple i guess i'm going to get
negative 2
this is going to give me
6 and then this is going to give me
negative
4. okay so this is a c and if you have a
think about it
it is yes you're going in the same
directions negative positive negative
negative positive negative
but you're not going as far you're going
two-fifths of the way
okay that looks good to me but it's
still not the question that i was trying
to answer
i was trying to find out where is where
is c this is just how to get from a
to c so how do i go further and the way
to
sort of calculate that if i bring this
over here i can do an extra
sort of a bit of construction here i can
say well let's
remember that the origin is somewhere
else in space
to get to c to work out what
that vector will be i can do that in
two pieces right i can go first from
i should start from motion though i can
go from o all the way up to a
and then a over to c which i've already
calculated so really what i want
to get to the corner to see is to do oa
and then add ac and that will get me
there so i can say
um oh c maybe i'll say i have a logical
conjunct
conjunction there but oc equals go to a
first
and then go from a to c and i know what
all those individual components
are oa of course is this original vector
here let's just grab that
and then i'm going to add on what i just
found
over here
so uh what's that going to be equal to
it looks to me like i'm getting
0 um three
and then six zero three six
those are my coordinates i can say z c
equals
zero comma three comma six uh using
vector methods so i divided up the
interval
in this particular ratio here knowing
that it'd be two-fifths of the way
and then i just put together my vectors
i compose them in the correct order to
give me the coordinates
that i was after now just before we
leave off
this question it is worth pointing out
that as with
what we've seen throughout the entire
topic of vectors because vectors are
defined as
direction and magnitude as we even saw
in this question direction
matters right the direction like a b
dividing that interval in a certain
ratio is different
to dividing the interval ba if you had a
look at this right
when i said this is a b and i'm dividing
in the ratio
2 to 3 my 2 is first and then my 3
was second so if i were dividing if i
was told to divide the interval ba
everything would be backwards so i would
find c not where i've located but it'd
be over here because this would be the 2
and this would be the three so helpful
way to remember it
um when you see this particular interval
here it's provided to you as
first a and then b the way i think about
it is i put the
interval in the order that's provided
underneath the ratio that's been
provided
so you've got a and then b you've got
two
and then three what this tells you
immediately you have a look at which
number is bigger right
the two is smaller the three is bigger
so what that means is i'm closer
to a than b
which you can of course see over here
where is c well it's closer to this side
than the other side if i was doing it in
the opposite direction
if i said doing it in the ratio 3 to
2 and again i've got a b under here
then because you can see the smaller
number is attached to the second
of my points that means i'm closer to b
than to a so this is important number
one for understanding what's going on
here
and also later on it's doubly important
when we're having a look at
external division of an interval
whatever that means
we'll get to it shortly